i think there's a lot going on in this
in this film the more outrageous the
role the more risky the situation right
johnny depp found himself in danger
repeatedly whether he was getting
trampled by horses hit by cars or
swashbuckling after you hear about these
15 dangerous scenes you won't wonder why
he used a stunt double so often but
before we dive in you should probably
subscribe to our new channel the things
animated to get all the hidden secrets
and unique theories behind your favorite
animated movies and shows
number one it's usually good advice
unless the plan is to get hit by a car
in which case the danger is inevitable
depp was filming mordecai in london and
he decided to take on a risky stunt
himself if you're gonna get hit by a car
repeatedly it might as well be a
gorgeous rolls-royce right although the
hood was still a pain to be bouncing off
of over and over
number two they weren't horsing around
nothing was funny about johnny depp's
horse co-stars on set who wound up
really putting him through the ringer
while filming the lone ranger depp was
thrown from the horse dragged across the
desert by it and he got a hoof stamp on
his chest to remember it all a giant
hoof-shaped bruise was left on his chest
but the actor bounced back from the
terrifying incident pretty quickly
looking on the bright side almost
immediately when he said the positive
thing is my coccyx didn't take it it was
after this incident that he stepped back
from the dangerous scenes a bit
number three don't go chasing waterfalls
let them come to you depp did just that
when he was filming his portion of
grindelwald's escape this stunt saw the
actors involved getting pelted with rain
and johnny got it pretty bad that said
he took it like a champ johnny stood
down his hose down and did everything
fantastic wanting the shots to look real
meant putting the actors in a dangerous
situation with the waterfall blast
hitting the actors as they tried to stay
on top of the carriage considering how
brutal this looks we're surprised deb
didn't let a stunt double take over
number four safety is important but it
can do some damage of its own to start
off this scene was wildly dangerous no
matter how you looked at it being
strapped onto a giant wheel that would
roll while there was a fight happening
on top of it not so fun depp managed to
get through the stunt but not without
some serious injury nerve damage anybody
yep johnny was strapped in so tight that
he actually got nerve damage in his foot
number five
you might not want to drink that filming
in venice should be a dream but when
your workplace is a risk to your health
well the situation is a bit different
depp learned this very quickly on set
for the tourist any scenes the actor
filmed that saw him coming into contact
with water hello boat chase scene were
risky situations because of the
pollution levels those beautiful
venetian canals looked great but they
were so polluted that every cast and
crew member who was going to interact
with water had to do antibiotics for
weeks before filming to avoid getting
sick
number six it was hard to win this one
captain jack sparrow managed to steal
the interceptor but it didn't happen so
gracefully depp came face to face with a
piece of wood that went flying once the
ropes of the ships became unstable and
started knocking everything else out of
place leading to some seriously
dangerous chaos depp got a nasty bruise
after being hit so hard by a piece of
wood that he got knocked right out of
the frame it seems they would want at
the spotlight
number seven leather plus florida heat
it's a bad situation you'd think the
scissor hands would be the most
dangerous part of depp's edward
scissorhands costume but nope it was his
black leather outfit leather is hot to
begin with that combined with the
florida sun and depth's intense
performance then you've got an actor in
danger of a bad case of heat stroke depp
fully collapsed when filming the scene
that saw edward running towards the
mansion evidently the cooling suit he
had on underneath didn't really help him
number eight johnny depp worried he cut
it a bit too close with rickman on the
sweeney todd set literally while rickman
was the one with the blade at his neck
it was depth that found the situation to
be quite a traumatic experience he
explained having worked with sharp
objects before everything was fine until
i have to shave someone the shaving
cream made me really nervous it was the
most uncomfortable moment of my life
looks like you won't be taking up being
a barber anytime soon
number nine it's not as fun as you might
think becoming a vampire is a real
process that's for sure but who knew one
of the biggest downsides could be
vampire nails no one on the set of dark
shadows was envying depp who had to very
carefully maneuver himself in any scene
he was performing in due to the
dangerously long nails the actor was
constantly worried about stabbing
himself or his fellow actors he even
required a full team to get to the
washroom winning costume the vampiric
accessories were so tough his nails and
fingers actually needed some pretty
serious tlc afterwards
number 10 he had a need for speed johnny
depp doesn't always do stunts but when
he did they were often car stunts one of
the most dangerous of all no big deal
public enemies saw a wicked car chase
but one that carried risk nonetheless
sure there were security people around
and trained drivers but with such high
action and speeds well it's never really
a safe situation
and definitely not one someone would
want to volunteer for
number 11. not a great place to swim you
might get a cavity while you're at it or
in johnny depp's case an allergic
reaction tim burton opted to use a
hundred and ninety two thousand gallons
of fake melted chocolate to fill the
rivers of wonka's factory the fear of
getting stuck trying to swim out of the
thick freaky liquid was lower on johnny
depp's worry list since the actor was
allergic to chocolate that's right folks
johnny couldn't indulge in the sweet
treat as a child however as an adult the
allergy wasn't so bad but it was still a
pretty terrifying idea to come to terms
with he was literally surrounded by a
surface that at one point could have
made him feel real bad
number 12. when swords are involved it's
never safe johnny depp faced danger
every time he started swashbuckling and
there was plenty of it throughout the
pirates movies oh yeah i had to go to
sword school yeah that said when things
got really risky johnny would step aside
letting his stunt double perform
those
enormous action sequences in the film
jumped up by gore verbinski and the
writer justin hath considering how sharp
and dangerous those blades could be no
wonder
number 13. looks cool safe not so much
of all the risky positions he's been in
for depp one of the worst was filming
his scenes inside a glass elevator he
had to be suspended very high up in the
air with seemingly nothing to hold him
in sure the large perspex box was safe
enough but he certainly didn't feel that
way falling from there would have done
some definite damage
number 14 they're no joke the last day
of filming was brutal for everyone on
city of lies with a whole lot to get
done in a short period of time but depp
might have had it the worst since he was
extremely ill we're talking fever the
sweats whole package a toothache turned
out to be a tooth infection and left him
sick for days but he did make it to the
last day on set though it wasn't so safe
for him to be there performing while
feeling so awful this definitely was not
a celebratory last day filming any of
his scenes was cause for concern depp is
ruining the film
number 15. it's getting cold in here the
sun might be shining bright but that
doesn't mean filming on the sea is
always a warm place to be some days
filming on the pirates of the caribbean
set could get so frigid that it actually
put those people being exposed in danger
depp knew this was a serious problem
especially for the crew who didn't have
the ability to be covered in layers of
blankets while working the way the actor
was so he came up with a solution for
everyone depp went ahead and bought
state-of-the-art cool temperature
jackets for all 500 crew members somehow
despite all the odds depth managed to
come out of these dangerous situations
mostly unscathed a few pulled muscles
and bruises are apart for the course in
this case though which scene would you
have been most intimidated to try
yourself
[Music]